[Musik]
und er schaut ihnen dankbar stark hoch
mehr
islam
[Musik]
si
die kerle
[Musik]
so zickig familie dar claudia und im
jakobi oder gruppe ließ erklären er
dürfte ariana und alessia auf der
bergfahrt landtag 2011 58er von soos
schweizerisch die zinskurve und
offensichtliche gesetz und claudio
untergrub auf viel gemeinsam
liebe zur natur zum beispiel
sie erinnert erklärt und so normal ist
ihren alltag aber immerhin ist er im
basketball profi und sie erfolgreiche
private sport stars können wie die mir
einfach mehr möglichkeiten zum der
berufsausübung nicht
es ist viel billiger zone und suvs
persönlich einfach da als glaube der
schweiz und dass sie die usa deutlich
weniger aufwand als bluesig frauen im
recht
in der schweiz sterben die leute war
nicht so gut
hier ist das völlig normal schweiz aber
eben weil ich mit ihm mit der schweiz
binden herms liegt auch lisa i
so ein großer sportler und vor allem im
bus haben ja so dass das ist
[Musik]
ich habe ihn nie so gedacht
ich hatte vorher nie eine partnerin aus
einem anderen land
es war nie ein thema es ist einfach
geschehen ich glücklicher single ab
teilt mentalität verschiedene mentalität
der show und prallt sie haben viele die
erfahrung gebracht und die möglichkeit
haben sind negativ erfahrung gemacht
wird
[Musik]
florence ist flight attendants sie hat
bis vor kurzem aus der klägerin
geschafft und bleibt mit der jüngere
tochter in derendingen die ältere
tochter laura ich muss sogar und kronen
ab und zu auf zu bleiben die dem große
usa 7
[Musik]
wie irland florence notar wohnt weiß sie
notieren money class ball zuzieht ist
ihre heimat schweden es für sie und
wütend reagiert und ihr euch alle zu
grüssen nicht rum der hauptbühne um den
hund kaufen und doch nicht so schlimm
vorgestellt aber also wenn er die rennen
zwischen ihm und den erhöhen wäre es
klar keine client einzig die beide über
facebook er hatte französische
dolmetscherin sucht und frau vom leiter
gefunden
[Gelächter]
es war nichts was mir wie hat jetzt
einmal reagiert wo natürlich keine
gelernten tier reagiert nur auf seite
traue ich ihnen schwer
ja also es ist ziemlich komisch sehr am
anfang wenn ehemalige kunde zwitter oder
aber es hat mir gott kommt nichts zu
verstecken und ich mit der sprache eines
problems so forschungsleiter für mich
humor und das ist natürlich auch wichtig
die familie passen
das hätte startschwierigkeiten kann ich
das also war ich am anfang ist der
wichtigste was die nicht durch das denke
ich habe also was dieser von ihm halte
sich wichtig wenn sie jetzt aber so wir
gehen jetzt kennen gar nicht wusste dass
das passieren dann wohl hier
dieser frauen oder hunde wegen und neuer
also duale studium bereitet geschminkt
auf schweden
naja das war heute zum nachteil weil ich
es noch nicht ganz genau
ja aber keine option
sie hat die kollegen bobby und groß und
[Musik]
wiegt nicht dass das tuch bezüglich aha
also das ist schon das haus wurde nichts
jetzt baut das ist so konzipiert dass
ist jetzt im wald ganz abfragen also an
dem wir gesagt dass allein das ist für
den rechten ja ja und ja sogar neuer dvz
not jetzt noch nicht ganz
ja und es rund aber nach wie vor wie es
jeder schau gleichen schwierigkeiten wie
ess- und welchen branchen recherche
großes thema und endlich wo du kannst
dass die irgendwann im schwäbischen sie
hofften natürlich habe es ist auch für
uns ein problem hat sogar dazu ehre und
das ist eine spezielle komisch da ich
musste mit der ratschlag aber also
traust du dir redet er über das heißt
das dass du an merkt dass es ihren und
dafür dass schwer oder schwere fahrzeug
möglichst natürlich hat das problem und
wenn sie in einem später gott ist ein
gesicherter sie nach wien auch gedanken
wie jetzt und so genau fließt hier
einfach so oder so also für mich das
nicht so klar setzte vermissen so aber
ich singe sich jedes lager oder wenn sie
dass gott und leuten ähnlich wie die
jungs zu interventionen mehr so sexy und
die finger bezeugen halterungen gut
verkraftet wird jetzt mal sagen wie ich
das wie die linke und der 1 genau wie
sie die ängste und dem moment das
wirklich was du willst
es ist schwierig so eine teenager sagt
seine 17
wo ich die unbeschränkte zeit die
harmonie uns gedanken machen sorgen und
80 wie sie praktisch mit deiner angst
dass er das ist schon es ist herten das
cash und und der vorschläge machen wie
das neue in zukunft die hoffnung gibt es
mal
heil ich sag jetzt mal oder er / sie
also dass wo immer im ruf steht und man
sich gedanken macht den euro dankbar bin
in eine schlechte mutter wenn jetzt
gleich oder ja also für mich ganz klar
lösung muss da sie bevor das ego ist
nötig denn fachleute
ferner muss es stimme ich stolz so davor
die rallye mexiko gedenken etwas angst
erich man sich so nicht unterstellen
dass die stadt ist ja logisch
psychisches engagement der partner also
was oder wer nicht schon beim crash die
frau weiter schwierig in der spd aus der
weniger zu akuten symptomen hartz iv wie
so eine panikattacke für mit problem mit
dem schulsachen erstellt muss natürlich
merken so zeigten die angst was ich
nicht gut finde ich dass du sehr offen
über das richtige für mich beste also
nach wenigstens ob sie das mich
vorsichtig chance auf das habe er mit
wir sagen es ist wieso man sich nehmen
uns dafür schämen
und es ist so wie jede andere krankheit
muss weil ich habe mir eigentlich nicht
[Musik]
ja
schwyz der riese trotzdem hat sie sich
hat da wohne ich mich am besten film und
ich alles verstehen und ich weiß ist
laut naturen größer und dünner als das
sind alles das auch beweisen können und
flugzeug bisschen und trockenfutter sind
zur sache wo das fleisch becker will und
das ist wohl ich bin ich die halter
fähig machen
[Musik]
bitte familie sturz von jens voigt sure
many die schwerter alles picobello und
schon vor wie den schmerz nach lebkuchen
ist sei man sie mischt sich aber auch
bieterin und will bald ist das so nicht
möglich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor 26 jahren sind sucht weil crew und
der hütte ins jeden tag mit denen
telefonieren und texten zwilling martina
und melanie die 22 jährige schon
speziell sind als wir sind immer noch da
das ist das buch in die hände spielten
ja es geht nämlich dass man sie die
schule 6000 wir sind noch alle freunde
der menschen auf klick und schon bin ich
hab sie auch braucht um ein seitlicher
oberstufe und braucht
[Musik]
martino
die aufgabe und mehr wahrnimmt und die
auch getrennt
sie werden damit sie jetzt die gunst
steht die woche konnte nicht sagen
dürfen immer noch entscheiden ob er
jetzt wenn zu sagen wenn sie einzeln
oder in irgendeiner mosaik sie auf
martina gefunden
das macht ja klar ich zum ausdruck kommt
ich meine ich das voll und ganz
nachvollziehen es macht und welche die
situation wirklich genau das gleiche
machen also vielleicht nur sagen dass
meine nachdem
nein ich glaube das einzige richtige
schon mal eine sondershow somit sagen
sie hätten sehen können
ich weiß wie so viel harmonie ist es das
problem dass martina und tk jp morgan
die älteren sind zum geldsparen eines
baumes wenn die beiden anruf australien
usw andere die heimat von kay wird es
für martina auch so schwierig wie es
wirklich war hier in der schweiz
ich glaube sie wird kaum
startschwierigkeiten haben sie spricht
jetzt schon mit australischem akzent
sie wird die umstellung gut meistern
wäre denkt dass es doch us kinos geplant
die liebe von der familie stets schon
bald ziemlich zu ende bringt
drunter und drüber stadt hin und weg
aber ich war glücklich sie und was
besten ist für ein sauber und was man
selber happy ich unglücklich und nicht
nur das
damit die anderen arbeiten
[Musik]
will ich bis vor der erfolgsrezept von
claudia und dem coup als binationales
bei dass sie weiter ihrem land lebt
sondern etwa in den usa wo sie bei die
ihre ganz individuelle erfolgsmoment
zuerst eher als basketball-star sie als
unternehmerin und bei die zimmer als
familie
[Musik]
am anfang mussten wir einen entscheid
fällen
ich spielte als profi sie tanzte in los
angeles
wir mussten entscheiden wer von uns
einen schritt zurück mal heute und dem
anderen zu folgen
sie gab ihren traum für uns auf und
unterstützte mich sie hat das ein paar
jahre gemacht und jetzt versuche ich das
gleiche für sie zu tun
sie verfolgt jetzt ihren thermals köchin
und ich folge hier dass sie zehn chöre
die beiden schnell und spontan ist der
entscheid zum horrortrip
das stadthaus wollte bereits schließen
als wir kamen alle stars der miami heat
kamen zur trauung
und so ließen sie uns rein alle wollten
autogramme von jermaine o'neal jailbreak
und all den jungs das war lustig wir
haben zweimal hochzeit gefeiert das war
im dezember und im juli noch machen ja
morgen der zehnter dezember ja morgen
sind es zehn jahre strahlen in den augen
so stauber sie arbeiten nicht die evo
große der öffentlichkeit in turtle
prosieben ist in der box ist was immer
der familie her schnitt so dass das
gezeigte straßen haben wir schon die
hand geben oder mal schnell so wenig in
wien öffentlich machen ist schwierig sie
aber es ist okay jetzt immer auch so mit
kollegen die meisten müssen was mit
ihnen wenn wir gerade jetzt so also
damit die
[Musik]
ach so gebündelt wird eigentlich nie
kompromiss und jedoch eigentlich um nach
reagiert also das ist noch schöner drauf
ich würde wirklich gerne wissen was du
jetzt gerade gesagt hast
[Musik]
als ich ein junge war haben wir eine
trüben gefischt und als sie sich einen
finger und den hochziehen und
abschneiden wollte schmidt ich mir in
den fingern es blutete und ich ging zu
diesem hotel da drüben
ich blutete unter frau und der rezeption
wurde es fast schlecht
entweder wird also bald florence ihre
heimat ihres fuß im wald liegt es bis
saal für die studenten stadt jönköping
[Musik]
geschick dafür so natürlich und das ist
immer interessant weil wir zum ist ihre
familien clan hat ist zu harmlos
[Musik]
ok
mit ihrer tochter noa ist florence in
regelmäßigem kontakt wenn sie schweden
ist natürlich erfundene nachts kosten
heimischer schlichten großteil von
familie der heime und dann kann man
liebe dich und du bist so wie das ist
sicher so schwierig ist mit uns
[Musik]
umso wichtiger sind unbeschwert im
moment in der fernbeziehung vom
schwedisch schweizerische neben
[Musik]
zu nehmen ist möglichst entspannt sie
haben zwar immer plänen aber dann
schauen wir wir lassen uns nicht
stressen
wir wollen nicht zu viel in ein
wochenende reinpacken
was wir heute nicht machen machen wir
morgen oder das nächste
ja
blüht sie eigentlich sehr offen sehr
unkompliziert ich glaube vor dem maintal
ii tat hat sie sie lebt für anders
aussieht also im weg
mit der großen unterschied aber wir
dürfen uns untergraben werden das war
ein schneiden als ich ihm sagen musste
dass er sonntags nicht rasen nehmen und
nach zehn uhr abends nicht mehr duschen
ich bot ihr an den rasen zu mähen doch
du nein nein es ist sonntag und wie er
mehr nicht am sonntag ein paar
wollsocken für neuer
nachdem sie unbedingt mitbringen
neuer pflückt juni das ist das problem
und laura wird jetzt mode mikro und dank
völlig im sommer treffen sich heute am
strang ziehen
ich glaube dass das haben wir jetzt mal
so plane der baum ihm sowohl microsoft
die schönen ausflug machen
[Musik]
spannende show stars wie claudia diawara
ganze spiel noch offen und amerika
braucht es überhaupt ins tour guide mit
catering oder mit hoch sondern
im ganz großen stil
frau passiert werden kann es mit dem
drauf
nach ihren anfang in der schweiz hat
claudia mit acht seine zirkusschule vom
cirque du soleil in montreal zucht reit
und ist aber dafür sind amerika wo ihrem
leiter prof
[Musik]
russland wurde möglichkeiten und ausland
wo mehr gleichheit dem sparkurs weil sie
verein bietet
am morgen ging ich ins team und meine
freunde fragten was machen wir
anschließend und ich sagte ach ich
heirate wo trifft man am samstagmorgen
sportbegeisterte familie trainingsplatz
[Musik]
dort richte ich weiß dass ich die zwei
in los angeles keine klaren trend aber
was ist es eigentlich gnauck sie wurde
zwei metern am anfang so fasziniert
zuerst fielen mir ihre coolen hosen auf
sie trug männer jeans wie eine hip hop
musikerin
sie trug ein rudel und diese ab ok astra
schnell alles gemacht um alle unbedingt
eine kleine doktor schön machen sie
wollte gar kein date mit dir kein bild
für dich
blöd für sie lasst es geschafft sie
umzustimmen
wir haben anfangs miteinander geplaudert
ihre freunde hatten von ihr erzählt
huser motor wir haben uns wieder
getroffen
dann fingen wir an mehr miteinander zu
sprechen erzählten einander von paris
von zürich es half mir dass die
französischsprachige schluss gemacht
es ist eigentlich neben denver miami
atlanta und zwischendurch immer wieder
psychische schweiz und frankreich
familie diawara führt das international
ausleben und ich meine hier eingespielt
ausschuss überhaupt realisiert was es da
für einen stellenwert hat nein gesagt
ist dass wir spielerisch oder
professionelle athlet
das hat mir nichts kein hockey und all
das zeugs aber nicht was das überhaupt
ist okay war das etwas das dich
angezogen hat dass sie eben kein fan war
ja sie kannte das nicht und das war gut
sie war nicht eine wie diese leute die
genau wissen was du tust und voller
bewunderung zu dir kommen
nur so kannst du die ware person sehen
ob du jemand wirklich machst so wie er
ist und nicht weil er der ist denn die
leute im fernsehen sehen
[Musik]
wir kommunizieren bei die nevigeser
mutter spruch und der falls doch mal
schwere emotionen oder vier wichtige
wurzel möglichkeit zum dann richtig
potenzial was eigentlich website
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eigentlich wohnte miklos aber wunderbare
norddeutschen shipping in småland
im sommer ist es mehr feeling einfacher
sehe ist und nicht das heuer am
sandstrand liegt und chris wasser das
mahl spd feeling
[Gelächter]
aber reden wild florence nur in
kombination mit sieben zahlt darf die
gez am stadtstrand bald passé
wenig los bald an die zukunft und die
elite halbe autostunde weg fordern
[Musik]
eigentlich ist die studie ist die
riesige barak danke und daran saugen
heute schweiz billig ist das nicht
gerade
es ist nicht geplant ja so heißt noch
nichts glich aber noch vor der heim und
doch ist er aber auf eine andere art
ganz anders
[Musik]
im eine-welt-laden küste von fetten sie
ein stück verkauft
[Musik]
auch ließ storz aufregung dass bei
fragezeichen und viel vorfreude spiele
florence und der nikolaus zu spüren wenn
sie ihre zukünftige die absurd
[Musik]
unser neues zuhause wohnen hier bis sie
aus noch dichte wolken auf
ich sehe aber einfacher so live im biz
stone steht auch nochmals anders
aber was bedeutet die initialen und b
die sind doch falsch oder obwohl 30 von
premier kan mit florence somit zweiter
vorname isabel und der trotz version ist
und eigentlich auch sie nicht freunden
und familie sagte mir so und darum hat
sich das mit dem b also übers gerät ist
von der wand gemacht hat hatte toni
tritt jetzt lasst uns zum haus gehen
das hier ist die garage in einer höhle
ja meine männer silvan hobbyraum ja da
werden keine autos erlaubt seien keine
frauen
ich mache entschlossen die tür
hier ja hier ist der eingang
wir stehen im haus wir sind in der hand
hier kommst du dann rein bringt die
hunde reihen voller dreck
du bringst sie bis hierher da gibt es
eine art badewanne für die hunde
du steckst sie rein abwaschen
dann kommen sie ins haus dafür liebt sie
mich weil ich solche sachen machen und
hier ist deine unsere waschmaschine die
wir öffnen zur großen terrasse
[Musik]
es ist für mich die einsamkeit der natur
russen im gegenteil also du bist die
bessere gesellschaft zu gesellschaft von
natur dukurs politik seit letzter woche
sido l und uwe fuchs wildschwein sie mit
der idee ist dass ein wechsel ab schon
wenn jetzt wieder hier steht am tag muss
ich sagen das ist keine einsamkeit das
ist es ist eine freude
[Musik]
am mittwoch 18 mehr als 22
martina und kay plötzlich schnell vor 24
stunden flug auf australien vorbereitet
neben anders kann ich ja im moment sehr
aktuell und beliebt wo manche schon für
jedes element der fluxus und besucher
vorrat und vielleicht einem
vertraulichen und dezember eigentlich
gestern das aus lübz ilo wieso vom
strahl mit und wie groß da steht fix vor
ihm flüge risch luther vorgezeichnet das
flugzeug flog sich ihnen als wenn jetzt
keine mio es ist ganz wichtig dass man
sich auf das ist alles kind das ist
alles verkauft es ist alles braun auf
der monat und fahrzeug diverse shops im
endeffekt eine halbjahr mit der planung
gestartet und ich weiß ja es war
verpasste
eigentlich hätte sie erst gegen hohe
stelen auswanderer
jetzt ist sie geblieben um sich so
richtig vor freunden und bekannten zu
verabschieden
immerhin die ganze familie schmidt zum
flughafen
für den augenblick und der innige
umarmung ist martina und dem check-in
beruhigen die nachrichten überholen
check das mehreren vereinen nachgefragt
mehrere tausend verstrahle und zum glück
die medien geraten dass ein familienzelt
und familienmitglieder die wanderreise
ich hoffe dass ich morgen veröffentlicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und denke kreis zurück mehr melanie und
martina die unzertrennlichen zwillinge 1
chiplead die ganze welt google zwischen
zivil
[Musik]
werden
sein
[Musik]
so hoch wie im buch zum grafen gestorben
basketball-profi zum husmann wird der
übergang wurde claudia ära der
inzwischen karriere und am kruppsee
sportliche grosserfolg im familienalltag
funktioniert zimmern ex woche voraus ich
wecke corona vor ihrem schwedischen
abgeschnitten
und ja das ist nowitzki wurde martina
und letzter sekunde ihres ziel erreicht
bevor als australien
ich konnte mich in die verstrahlen
austragen
[Musik]
tödtmann